bien tenemos f x igual a 4x a la quinta
menos 3x cuadrada más 3 sobre 6x a la
quinta menos 100 x cuadrada menos 10 y
en lo que quiero que pensemos es cuál es
el límite cuál es el límite de fx
nuestra función cuando x se aproxima a
infinito y hay varios caminos en cómo
podemos hacer esto pensarlo por ejemplo
podemos tratar de ir dándole valores
grandes a equis y ver si se aproxima a
algún valor en específico o también
podemos razonar y ver el comportamiento
de dicho cociente para cuando x se
aproxima a valores realmente grandes y
hablando de esto a lo que me refiero es
que si x es muy muy grande nos
concentramos por ejemplo en la parte del
denominador en cuanto a estos términos
que tenemos por aquí este que estoy
encerrando dominaría en la parte de
arriba del cociente pues el hecho de que
este término esté elevada a una potencia
a las 5 haría significativamente grande
el número imagínate pues con respecto a
los otros aunque éste esté elevado
al cuadrado no sería algo grande
comparado cuando algo está elevada a la
quinta pues se incrementa mucho más
rápido lo mismo sucede aquí abajo aunque
este número esté elevado al cuadrado y
luego lo multiplicamos por 100 no afecta
de gran manera a nuestro primer término
que sea que denominaría puesto que es un
término muy grande que le estaríamos
dando la potencia de 5 entonces en
realidad esto será equivalente a solo
poner nuestros términos dominantes y
claro esto hablando para cuando tomamos
x demasiado grandes entonces esto sería
para cuando x se aproxima a infinito y
como ves quizás por aquí podríamos
simplificar nuevas nuestra función pues
tenemos 4x a la quinta sobre 6x a la
quinta podemos cancelar dichos términos
y decir que esto es igual a dos tercios
por lo tanto este límite cuando x se
aproxima a infinito y quitamos esta
parte del cociente puesto que no son tan
dominantes con respecto a los otros
términos podemos decir que es igual a
dos tercios pero bueno ahora déjame
por aquí poner la gráfica y veamos como
todo esto tiene sentido y también
analicemos dicha gráfica podemos
observar que tendríamos una a sin total
para cuando llegue es igual a dos
tercios en realidad esta gráfica la
saqué de un programa para graficar que
es wolfram alpha y pensemos que para
cuando x es muy pero muy grande
efe aquí se está aproximando a este
valor que podemos decir que está
alrededor de dos tercios así que mira
como tenemos una asín total horizontal
por aquí y deja la dibujo mejor cada vez
más cerca y decimos que esta gráfica es
para cuando oye es igual a dos tercios
entonces el límite para cuando x es muy
muy grande cuando hay que se aproxima a
infinito se acerca muchísimo a dos
tercios y ahora si vemos hacia el lado
izquierdo podríamos asegurar que luce
igual para cuando x aproxima a menos
infinito entonces escribamos por aquí el
límite de fx pero para ahora cuando de
que se aproxima menos infinito
y forma en cuanto a la función nos van a
interesar los valores dominantes que
seguirán siendo los mismos entonces
conforme x tiende para esta dirección
hacia menos infinito vemos que dicho
valor también se acerca hacia dos
tercios entonces cómo podrás darte
cuenta esto es verdad para cuando x se
aproxima términos positivamente muy
grandes y negativamente muy grandes
también entonces estos son los términos
dominantes se vuelven a cancelar y
podemos asegurar que dicho límite por
esta parte también se aproxima a dos
tercios y de esta forma se ve reflejada
su asiento está horizontal una vez más y
si se te facilitó esta forma de ver los
límites puedes usar esta técnica de
concentrarte en los términos que
predomina en la función para facilitarte
las cosas entonces como te diste cuenta
esto lo hace más sencillo